welcome back so today I'm going to talk
about model reduction and in particular
we're going to talk about balanced model
reductions so I'm just going to write
this down
balanced model reduction a lot of the
ideas I'm going to talk about today in
the context of model reduction are also
going to be useful for system
identification
so remember model reduction is when you
have a model but it's too big to use for
control and we're gonna try to find a
smaller model that captures most of the
dynamic features I'll tell you what I
mean by balanced in a little bit but
most of what I'm going to talk about
with balanced model reduction again
applies to system identification so
let's just put this into some context
here remember we have some system that
system is going to eventually we hope be
controlled so we're gonna try to control
the system we're gonna take some
measurements Y and the control law is
going to give some actuator signal you
some control knob you that it has
control over to change the dynamics and
behavior of this system so everything
I'm going to talk about for the next few
lectures are going to be with respect to
linear dynamical systems not nonlinear
system idea but purely linear so we're
going to assume that our system is X dot
equals ax plus B u y equals CX and to
start with we're going to assume that we
know what the dynamics are we have a
model for a B and C but X is really
really big way too big to use so X is in
let's call this our n that means there's
n degrees of freedom needed to describe
the system X let's put vector notation
under this matrices we'll have double
okay maybe you and Y are vectors as well
so this vector X is a really really
really really high dimensional state of
my system n might be a million or a
billion degrees of freedom if this is a
turbulent fluid discretized onto a grid
or if this is the state of a the state
of a disease
system in a country maybe this is every
individual in that country maybe there's
80 million people okay so if this is a
very high dimensional vector the goal of
model reduction is to find a new system
that captures most of the input to
output dynamics it captures most of the
the into out dynamics but with a much
much smaller state than X okay so well
we'll walk through this in a minute and
I'll tell you what I mean by balanced
later so the goal okay the goal what
we're going to do is we're going to
start with a system like this I'm just
going to write it over here X dot equals
ax plus B u y equals CX now if I'm a
control theorist I do care what the
dynamics are I care what the dynamics of
X the internal state of the system are
if it oscillates or if it grows
exponentially if it's unstable if it's
decays really fast I care what those are
but what really matters to me is if I
kick the system with my control input
with my actuation u if I if I
impulsively kick the system with what I
can force it with what happens to the
measurements Y those will be a function
of the dynamics of because their
measurements of the state so I kicked
the system I get some transient response
maybe it's even unstable and then I
measure some portion of the state in my
measurements Y and that's going to be my
input to output so input u output Y what
I really want to do is I want a smaller
model in terms of a smaller state so
that most of those dynamics from input
to output are captured okay so what I
really want is a new state let's call
this X tilde okay so tilde is my reduced
state this is my full high D this is
going to be my reduced low D state okay
this is going to capture most of the
behavior of X but in a much much smaller
and we're gonna call this our R so I'm
only going to use little R degrees of
freedom for this
we're little are is much much much less
than n okay so what I want to do is I
want to write this in terms of a new
system in terms of this small state
let's write that down okay so what I'm
gonna have is X tilde dot the time
derivative of my reduced state is going
to equal a tilde X tilde plus B tilde U
and then my measurements Y are going to
equal C tilde X tilde so notice that you
and why didn't change okay I still have
the same input I can't reduce that input
it's it's what I have the ability to
control in my car I'm a steering wheel
and a gas pedal and a brake that's you
okay why are my measurements those don't
change either the only thing that's
changing is how I represent the internal
dynamics of the state of the system in
terms of X tilde instead of X and X
tilde is many many fewer degrees of
freedom it's only the essential
information that most matters for
modeling what happens from input to
output so sometimes I kind of think of
this as a black box okay from use two
wise and I want to just find some
minimal linear model in terms of tilde
variables that captures most of the
energy from you to lie
and remember for control design the
reason I don't want a million
dimensional X vector is because my
control would be huge my lqr control
would now be this million sighs feedback
matrix so what I want to do instead is I
want to be able to characterize these
dynamics in terms of a much much smaller
state that's R dimensional which will
make it much faster to predict and to
actuate and that faster actuation
because I'm only evaluating a small
model will essentially allow me to have
much lower latency higher bandwidth
control okay so really this is just a
fundamental hardware problem I can't
simulate a million dimensional system
fast enough to get good high bandwidth
control on the timescales of the system
I care about so I want a reduced
representation that I can simulate
faster
more attractively it's as simple as that
okay so the goal is to find these new
coordinates X tilde and a new dynamics a
tilde B tilde C tilde that best captured
the input-output dynamics from u to Y
and what we are also going to assume is
that we can reconstruct our state X from
these X tilde so there's going to be
some big matrix I I like besides like I
Poseidon in terms of X tilde so if I
want to draw this just in terms of
pictures remember X is a really really
really really tall vector million
dimensional vector of all the states but
maybe there are only a few a small
handful of dominant patterns that are
exhibited by these million dimensional
dynamics maybe you know if I'm looking
at flow over a wing in the million
degrees of freedom space I always see
big vortices forming and shedding okay
so there's a few dominant patterns that
I see all the time those are captured in
this matrix I so this matrix I might
have five or ten columns each of which
is the size of X those each column is a
pattern a dominant pattern in my system
and then little X tilde is a five
dimensional vector that tells me which
of those five patterns are active at
this particular moment in time for the
state X and so basically I can I can
approximate my big high dimensional
vector by finding some mixture of these
dominant patterns that I've seen in the
data so patterns live in sigh X tilde
are the low dimensional coefficients of
those patterns maybe five or ten of them
are might be five or ten and then I can
reconstruct my high dimensional state by
just multiplying back so okay I can
develop my controller here I can develop
my model here and if I want a pretty
picture to see what's actually happening
in my system I just reconstruct with sy
and I get my full vector X very cool so
this is basically the goal is to find so
this is my original system this is my
original I want to find a new system in
terms of this new state X tilde that's
much much smaller than X
that best captures the input to output
dynamics from Yuda why now best captures
input to output dynamics is a little bit
vague but there are ways of actually
formalizing what that means in terms of
mathematics and we'll do that in a bit
let me give you a really really simple
example that illustrates some of these
ideas ok so a really simple example
let's let's make a two-state system so
this isn't really you know fancy high
dimensional model reduction but let's
assume that n is 2 and I want to find a
1 dimensional approximation R is 1 so
we're gonna write D DT of x1 x2 equals
ok and I'm going to write down an a
matrix and a B matrix X 1 X 2 plus you
have a B matrix times u and I'm going to
measure y equals some C matrix times X 1
X 2 so let me just write down what the
numbers are and then we'll work work
through this problem okay so the numbers
I'm gonna have minus 2 0 0 minus 1 now
if I didn't think about controllability
and observability remember from the
control bootcamp there are these
observability and controllability
grampians that tell me what directions
in state space are most controllable and
most observable so if I had a gallon of
gas in my tank and you which directions
an X I could go farthest along and if I
had some measurement with noise Y what
states of X could I best estimate if I
didn't think about any of that if I
forgot everything I know about control
theory if I wanted to pick one of these
states to capture the best captures of
the dynamics I would probably pick the X
to state I would write a new system just
x2 dot equals minus x2 because this
minus 1 eigen value is more lightly
damped than this minus 2 eigen value the
x1 dynamics are decoupled from x2 and
they're going to die out faster right if
I if I just started with x1 equals x2
equals 1 the vector 1 1 the x1 dynamics
are going to decay faster than the x2
dynamics so I'm gonna see these sticking
around for a lot longer
so if I was naive and all I cared about
in the universe was a I would probably
pick the x2 variable
I'd probably reduce out by killing x1
and only keeping x2 because this is a
more lightly damped eigenvalue now this
is where it gets interesting for lots of
systems that is that that intuition is
wrong so let me give you this these new
variables so now the B matrix is going
to be 1 and 10 to the minus 10 okay big
teeny-tiny and here I'm gonna do the
same thing the first element of C is
going to be 1 and then this is 10 to the
minus 10 so now you can see that
choosing x2 solely because it had
lightly damped dynamics that we're gonna
stick around longer was a terrible idea
this is kind of an exaggeration because
you barely effects x2 at all and I can
kick you a thousand times harder and
it's it's not going to affect x2 nearly
as much as it affects x1 just because of
this second component that my B matrix
is tiny so everyone see that so the way
that the actuation affects the state is
through this B matrix and because the
second component is tiny no matter what
I do to you it's not going to affect x2
so even if these dynamics are more
dominant they're not controllable at all
the x2 direction is not barely
controllable similarly even if I could
muster enough energy to kick x2 I can
barely measure it it barely barely comes
out in my sensor measurement because
that's 10 to the minus 10 so in this
example it becomes very clear that we
can't simply make decisions based on one
matrix a we have to consider a and B and
C and in this case the reduced dynamics
the the dynamics that make the most
sense is actually to keep the X 1
variable and say the best approximation
from u to Y in terms of one variable is
just x tilde equals x one we're going to
kill the X 2 variable even though it has
stronger dynamics and I'm gonna get X 1
dot equals -2 X 1 plus U and I'm gonna
get y equals x 1
this reduction from two variables to one
variable is by far the best way of
capturing the u2y dynamics okay so this
is just like a very very simple example
of what we're going to be doing we're
gonna develop a formal theory for how to
find these coordinates X tilde and this
coordinate transformation this is just a
coordinate transformation okay
coordinate transformation we're gonna
find a coordinate transformation into
new better coordinates where I still
capture most of my input-output energy
from you to why based on these matrices
a B and C okay and that's what balance
means okay so I told you I would I would
mention what balance model reduction
means there's a million different ways
of choosing a reduced order model my
naive approach just going based on the
eigen values of a was wrong in this case
what balance model reduction does is it
balances it finds states that balance
the controllability of that state with
the observability and that's really what
I want to do i I want to I I want to
care more about states that are
simultaneously easy to control and easy
to observe because if I have a state
that is not controllable or observable I
don't care about it at all if I have a
system that's very controllable but
barely observable even if I control it
I can't measure it so it's hard to
control based on that and similarly if I
have a state that's really easy to
measure but I can't control it at all I
don't want to care about that either so
what I really care about is finding
States these dominant patterns these
states these are these these columns of
Si are directions in state space that
are most jointly controllable and
observable and we're going to quantify
that with the controllability and
observability graeme ins so if you need
a refresher just go back to the control
bootcamp and kind of get caught back up
on controllability and observability
graeme ins because that's what this is
all gonna be based on okay thank you